a young woman born into a polygamist
cult base in Salt Lake City is speaking
in public for the very first time after
exposing an alleged multimillion-dollar
business fraud by members of the clan
Mary Nelson is her name she escaped Utah
Utah's Kingston clan or the order it's
also called that a breakaway Mormon
group with the help of her now husband
Brian the couple work with the IRS and
the FBI to uncover an alleged 500
million dollar scam in tonight's episode
of whistleblower Nelson discusses her
journey from Kingston Klan member to
government informant with host judge and
former police officer Alex Ferrer meri
who are these individuals those are all
my siblings do you miss me yes I miss
them very very much when I found out
that Mary's father had over 200 children
I knew something was very wrong
my father has 18 wives Mary Nelson is
telling all how she became an unlikely
whistleblower against prominent members
of her own family this is the work of
the Lord the Kingston clan they give you
instructions they say don't ask
questions on February 10th 2016 after
going to the federal government a series
of events that Mary helped set in motion
exploded a major show of force at
several businesses owned by the Kingston
polygamist group the raids were part of
an investigation into an alleged money
laundering scheme funding lavish
lifestyles of some prominent Kingston's
from mansions to exotic cars while other
members live near the poverty line it
was more like an organized crime family
Mary might never have become a
whistleblower if she hadn't meant Brian
Nelson a fellow student at Salt Lake
Community College who helped her escape
the Klan after she says she was ordered
to marry her 17 year old cousin there
was nothing that was gonna get in my way
of stopping this after the escape the
couple married and eventually had two
children hey how was preschool today
buddy Mary told Brian what she had seen
while working at the Kingston's own
private bank did you forge documents
when you work there yeah so we were
given just stop
some stacks of checks and just signing
them signing them and they would just
deposit that just whatever account they
needed Washakie renewable energy appears
to be the most profitable business owned
by group members so when Mary was
telling me if this is the biggest
company that the order has I started to
immediately suspect fraud according to
the government washi Kees founders
brothers Jacob and Isiah Kingston
falsified the company's tax filings to
obtain a massive five hundred eleven
million dollars worth of fraudulent tax
credits right then and there I said we
gotta me that's the beginning of the end
what made you decide to become a
whistleblower we didn't know that that's
what we were we knew that something had
to change
were you ever afraid that the Kingston
group would find out that you and Brian
were the informants and went to the FBI
I'm so very very scared about that you
were afraid that they were gonna hunt
you down yeah the Kingston group says it
condemns in the strongest terms
fraudulent business practices and they
stressed that this behavior goes
completely against our beliefs and
principles it also says that business
owners who are members of the group have
the autonomy to make their own business
decisions
Alex Ferrer joins us at the table this
is a very troubling story she just
mentioned that she was scared and afraid
so how worried are they about
retaliation Maryann Brian was very
worried and rightfully so court records
revealed text messages from Jacob
Kingston one of the brothers relating to
an enforcer where he asks for a
two-for-one deal and a bulk discount and
the government alleges that the two
brothers hired an enforcer to intimidate
and harm witnesses and the text messages
seem to pretty clearly point to the
whistleblowers Wow 18 wives more than
200 children basically children it seems
according to whistleblowers are used
like an ATM they they they're the basis
for a lot of different fraud against the
government which they call bleeding the
Beast
Alex ingrained it's a troubling story
indeed Alex good to see you again good
to see you too you can watch
whistleblowers new episode polygamy
power and profits the case against the
Kingston's ends tonight 8:00 7:00
central right here on CBS